Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
Cambly una plataforma para practicar
inglés de forma individual con
tutores nativos especializados.
Muy, muy interesante.
No es ningún secreto que últimamente la República
Popular China no es precisamente
el país más popular del mundo.
Cosas como el coronavirus, el asalto a Hong Kong,
las constantes amenazas contra Taiwán, o
los problemas con los préstamos a países
pobres han colocado a China directamente
en la lista de los países más antipáticos.
Y eso no es todo. Para colmo una nueva política
está contribuyendo gota a gota a machacar su
popularidad en el exterior. Me estoy refiriendo a
la nueva diplomacia establecida por Xi Jingping.
Un tipo de diplomacia mucho
más dura y beligerante que
se ha bautizado extraoficialmente como la
diplomacia del lobo guerrero; y que muchos
analistas identifican básicamente como
una estrategia de chantaje y coacción.
Una estrategia que la verdad, con los
datos en la mano, no parece que esté siendo
particularmente efectiva. No al menos de cara a
la popularidad del país en el resto del mundo.
(Fijaos un momento en este gráfico. En apenas
cinco años, entre la primavera del 2015 y el
verano del 2020 la opinión de China se ha
desplomado en muchas de las principales
economías del mundo. De ser un país de moda a
ser visto con muchos recelos. Algo que en cierto
modo tiene que ver con la propia forma con la que
China se está relacionando con el resto del mundo)
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este
vídeo vamos a conocer de cerca la
llamada diplomacia del lobo guerrero, vamos a
echar un vistazo a la nueva forma con la que
China ha decidido castigar a cualquier
adversario que se cruce en su camino.
[Pero antes, os quiero hablar de Cambly
una plataforma para practicar y mejorar
tu inglés que es súper interesante. Con
ella vamos a poder terminar de una vez y
para siempre con la pesadilla más habitual
en el mundo hispano: el dominio del inglés.
Desde tu casa y con solo un ordenador,
podrás conectarte con uno de los miles
de tutores nativos que hay en Cambly.
Estoy seguro de que encontrarás un tutor a
medida para ti en función de tus necesidades.
¿Qué quieres mejorar tu inglés
aplicado a los negocios? Pues,
tendrás tutores expertos en este campo.
¿Qué lo necesitas para viajar? Pues
encontrarás tutores nativos que te
ayudarán con ello. Necesites el inglés para
lo que lo necesites, con Cambly tendrás a
tu disposición toda una plataforma de clases
individuales que se adapta a tus necesidades. Y
todo cómodamente desde el lugar que tu quieras.
Ya os lo dije: es algo muy, muy interesante.
Y eso no es todo. Ahora para ayudarte
a conseguir tus objetivos, Cambly te
regala un cupón con un 50% de descuento
en todos los planes anuales. Así es,
¡podrás aprender inglés todo el
año y 6 meses te saldrán gratis!
Ah, ¡importante! Todos los que
os registréis podréis probar
el servicio durante 10 minutos de
forma completamente gratuita. Sin
compromisos. Esto sí que es empezar
con buen pie el 2022, ¿no os parece?
Introducid el código VISUALPOLITIK2022
en Cambly, o VISUALPOLITIK2022KIDS en
Cambly Kids a la hora de seleccionar un
plan y conseguirás este descuento único.
No pierdas el tiempo y empieza
a aprender inglés desde ya con
tu propio tutor nativo individualizado.]
Dicho esto, continuemos.
(CHINA SACA LOS DIENTES)
Querida comunidad de VisualPolitik la China
moderada, la China de las palabras mesuradas
y las acciones tranquilas parece
haber desaparecido por completo.
Esa China tranquila que tanto deseaba
Deng Xiaoping ha dejado de existir. Xi
Jinping ha terminado con ella. Ahora
es el tiempo de los lobos guerreros.
(La diplomacia del lobo guerrero no ha
supuesto un mero cambio de política exterior,
sino todo un cambio de concepto y de visión
sobre el papel de China en el mundo y sobre
como Pekín quiere hacer valer su cada vez
mayor peso económico y militar. Es algo
así como un “ya estamos aquí y vamos
a tomarnos en serio nuestro papel”.)
Tan simple y a la vez tan complejo.
Pero, ahora bien, ¿En qué consiste
exactamente este tipo de diplomacia?
¿Cómo se lleva a cabo?¿Qué cambios ha conllevado?
Bien, uno de los cambios más importantes ha
sido el enfoque militar. Para ser un lobo
guerrero hay que ser capaz de infundir miedo,
y eso exactamente lo que ha hecho China con
la mejora de sus capacidades militares y
con su creciente nivel de beligerancia en
la región. Os hablamos de todo ello en
un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
Sin embargo, el terreno militar no es
el único que ha experimentado cambios.
El nuevo estilo de diplomacia china
va mucho más allá del poder militar.
(La diplomacia del lobo guerrero es una visión
integral. Y la primera línea de batalla se sitúa
precisamente en el personal diplomático.
Buena parte del personal de las embajadas
y consulados chinos ahora tiene la misión
concreta de alimentar la desinformación,
fabricar fake news o buscar y apoyar a periodistas
y comunicadores afines. La línea roja se ha
desplazado. Ya no se trata de hilar fino sino de
ejercer un claro activismo, cueste lo que cueste.)
Digamos que la diplomacia china
ha descubierto las redes sociales.
(Ejército de fans falsos refuerza
mensajes de China en Twitter - AP)
Claro que esto ocurre en las redes
sociales y también fuera de ellas.
Pero por supuesto, es solo la punta
del Iceberg.Un instrumento más en
una estrategia que tiene en los castigos
políticos y económicos su elemento clave.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. Xi Jinping ha
decidido que China tiene que
castigar a sus adversarios.
Atentos porque con lo que os vamos
a contar a continuación vais a poder
comprender una parte importante de la actualidad.
(SACAR LOS PIES DEL TIESTO
CON PEKÍN… TIENE PRECIO)
El castigo político y económico por encima
del control territorial. Si tanto Rusia,
como Estados Unidos, Francia o el Reino
Unido llevan décadas preocupados por el
control territorial y la influencia
militar China está focalizando todos
sus esfuerzos en utilizar su dos
grandes ventajas competitivas:
Su posición como la fábrica del mundo y su inmensa
población. Para conocer cómo se las
gasta el gigante asiático tanto solo
tenemos que echar un vistazo a los casos
de Corea del Sur, Australia y Lituania.
Tres países muy diferentes y muy distantes
entre sí, que sin embargo tienen algo en común:
han vivido en sus carnes lo que
supone enfadar a Xi Jinping.
(En 2017 el gobierno de Corea del
Sur decidió autorizar la instalación
del sistema antimisiles estadounidense THAAD en su
territorio. Algo a lo que China se opuso
frontalmente desde un primer momento.
Según Pekín, los potentes radares
estadounidenses podrían ser
utilizados para seguir los movimientos
militares de China en su propio país.
Pese a ello, en aquel momento en Corea del
Sur la tensión estaba por las nubes por las
constantes pruebas con misiles intercontinentales
que estaba llevando a cabo Corea del Norte. Así
que a pesar de la férrea oposición china, Seúl
terminó dando el Ok al despliegue del THAAD)
¿El resultado? El gobierno chino
promovió una campaña salvaje de
boicot económico contra las empresas surcoreanas.
El primer efecto fue la paralización del turismo
chino, que se desplomó un 50% y le costó a las
empresas surcoreanas pérdidas multimillonarias.
Luego llegó el boicot directo a empresas,
como ocurrió con el Grupo Lotte, el grupo
empresarial surcoreano que era dueño del campo
de golf donde se instaló el THAAD. Pues bien,
este grupo tenía un importante negocio de
hipermercados en China bajo la marca Lotte
Mart, a los que de repente la gente
dejó de ir. Digamos que el gobierno
chino se encargó de que estuviera
mal visto comprar en sus tiendas.
Y por supuesto, cualquier licencia para
abrir nuevos establecimientos quedó también
congelada. La empresa tuvo que terminar
anunciando su salida completa de China.
De la misma forma, millones de chinos
dejaron de comprar vehículos Hyundai y Kia,
móviles y electrodomésticos de
Samsung, y un largo etcétera.
Todo esto hasta que en 2019, dos años
después del inicio de las sanciones
chinas, Pekín decidió que ya había sido
suficiente y dio el asunto por zanjado.
Sin embargo… otros países no han
tenido tanta “suerte”. Echemos
un vistazo por ejemplo al caso de Australia.
Y es que veréis, a pesar de su estrecha
alianza con Estados Unidos, Australia es
un importante socio comercial de China que proveé
al gigante asiático de todo el carbón, hierro y
gas que su industria necesita. Y también de una
enorme variedad de productos agroalimentarios.
De hecho entre los años 2009 y 2019, las
exportaciones australianas a China se
triplicaron hasta superar los
110 mil millones de dólares.
(Todo saltó por los aires en 2020, cuando el
gobierno de Australia pidió una investigación
internacional independiente sobre los orígenes
de la pandemia del Sars-coronavirus-2.
Ese fue un auténtico punto de inflexión.
Apenas una semana después de la petición
australiana, el embajador chino en Canberra,
Chen Jingye, amenazó con un boicot económico. Algo
que, por supuesto, no tardaron en poner en marcha.
Por ejemplo, redujeron progresivamente
las importaciones de carbón australiano
hasta llevarlas a cero e introdujeron
un montón de aranceles a muchas de las
importaciones que China compraba en este país.)
La cebada, la carne, el vino, el cobre,
la madera… El castigo fue considerable.
Pero, ¿Sabéis qué? El tiro a los chinos
les salió por la culata. Canberra no sólo
no cedió sino que cambió por completo su
política exterior. ¿Os suena de algo AUKUS,
la nueva alianza entre Australia,
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido?
Seguro que sí, hemos hablado de ella
recientemente aquí en VisualPolitik.
Pues bien, ese acuerdo tuvo mucho que ver
con la historia que os estamos contando.
Ya sabéis que casualidades las justas.
(El equilibrio de décadas de Australia
entre EE. UU. y China ha terminado.
Han elegido Washington - CNN)
(Australia obtendrá el primero de
sus submarinos nucleares CINCO AÑOS
antes de lo previsto mientras Estados
Unidos acelera el proyecto de $90.000
millones frente a las crecientes
tensiones con China - DailyMail)
Por cierto, que la estrategia del
lobo guerrero en el caso de Corea
del Sur tampoco valió para mucho. El Thaad
continuó desplegado a pesar del boicot.
Si algo o parece que convertirse
en el abusón de la clase le esté
sirviendo de nada a China. De hecho
el país de Xi Jinping atraviesa su
peor momento diplomático desde
que comenzara el nuevo siglo.
Pero aún no hemos terminado. El último
ejemplo de estas campañas de acoso y
castigo lo encontramos ni más ni menos que
en un país de la Unión Europea: en Lituania.
(Preocupado por la creciente
intromisión política de China,
Lituania decidió retirarse del grupo 17+1, una
iniciativa de Pekín que buscaba aglutinar todos
los países del centro y este de Europa.
Algo que en Pekín no hizo ninguna gracia.
Pero con todo, la gota que desbordó el
vaso fue la autorización que Vinilnus
dio a Taiwán para que este gobierno
abriera una oficina de representación
en la capital lituana y que para colmo lo
hiciera con su propio nombre. Es decir,
Oficina de Representación de Taiwán
en lugar de Oficina de Representación
de Taipei que es la fórmula más habitual.
A partir de ese momento comenzó el castigo.
El gobierno chino eliminó a Lituania como
opción de origen en el despacho de aduanas,
lo que implica que las empresas
de esta pequeña república báltico
no pueden exportar sus productos
directamente al gigante asiático.)
Y eso no es todo. El gobierno chino también está
presionando a compañías europeas que fabrican en
la propia China para que dejen de utilizar
componentes del país báltico. Este ha sido,
por ejemplo, el caso del fabricante alemán
de componentes de automoción, Continental.
(Las exportaciones lituanas prácticamente
desaparecieron del mercado chino en medio de
la disputa de Taiwán. Los datos aduaneros chinos
muestran en diciembre una caída del 91,4% en las
exportaciones del estado báltico. SCMP)
Claro que, tal y como hemos visto en
los casos anteriores, el castigo
no parece haber servido de mucho.
Lituania ha continuado estrechando
lazos con Taiwán y, ahora, la Unión
Europea se plantea tomar represalias.
(La UE diseña nuevas medidas contra la
"coacción económica". La Comisión Europea
ya no quiere soportar un chantaje económico
como el ejercido por China. DW)
(Francia busca una acción rápida
contra China para rescatar a Lituania
en la guerra comercial - Politico)
Os hemos hablado largo y tendido de esta
cuestión en las Claves de la Semana,
el boletín que recibís todos
los que nos apoyáis en Patreon.
En fin, de momento parece que la diplomacia
del lobo guerrero no está cosechando muchos
éxitos. No funcionó en Corea, no funcionó en
Australia y no está funcionando en Lituania.
Tampoco en Taiwán cuando en 2016 China
comenzó un boicot contra el turismo y
los intercambios de estudiantes tras
la primera victoria de Tsai Weng,
y no se puede decir que funcionó
en Canadá con el caso Meng Wanzhou.
Lejos de ello, la posición diplomática
de China parece hoy mucho más endeble y
expuesta de lo que era hace unos pocos
años. En Pekín parecen no saberlo pero
en ocasiones el diálogo, la negociación
tranquila y los gestos de buena voluntad
consiguen mejores resultados que la
fuerza, el chantaje y la coacción.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para
tí: ¿Qué te parece la diplomacia del
lobo guerrero empleada por China? ¿Cómo
deben los países afectados enfrentarse
a ella? ¿Qué tienen que hacer las
grandes potencias internacionales?
Dejanos tu opinión por aquí abajo
en los comentarios.Y como siempre,
si te ha gustado el vídeo no olvides
darle like y suscribirte a nuestro
canal para estar al día de todas
las novedades que están por venir.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar
ahí. ¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!